Ingrid is with us in Indianapolis hi
Ingrid how are you I'm fine thank you
very much for taking my call my question
is we are about 65 years old we're
already retired and we are getting ready
to purchase a car a financial adviser is
recommending that we leverage our money
and we're getting about 8% return on our
investment and the loan for a car loan
would be about 3% interest and so she is
recommending that we get the car loan
one thing to add is that if we do
finance the car we are getting a $2,500
rebate so those are the quick facts and
if you could advise us what you called
Dave Ramsey about a car line I did know
no hope in you know hey well you knew
what the facts were going to be when you
called me why do you not want to do this
you don't believe it or not well I'm I'm
concerned I've been brought up old
school there we go there we go she my
lady she violated your common sense with
her stupid but suggestion didn't she I
don't know if a be she did honestly the
majek makes sense the logic is not does
not make sense
there's a reason old school is smart
she's leaving out risk okay you have
another car right now do you own a car
we do it's logical logic makes sense and
go borrow on that and invest with her
I'm going to go beyond telling you to
not buy the car not only unless you pay
cash for it I'm going to tell you to
fire your financial adviser she's an
idiot that's an absolute ridiculous
stupid piece of advice tell a 65 year
old to go borrow money on a car after
they work their whole life to be
debt-free and build up their investments
because you got your stupid butt MBA
somebody ought to kick that woman's butt
up around her neck that's awful advice
hope I wasn't unclear this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]